effectivement les bombardements sont
extrêmement régulier on entend tout le
temps en fait un en journée pendant la
nuit cette nuit d'ailleurs il ya des
bruits de détonation qui nous ont
réveillés à 4 heures du matin l'immeuble
en à trembler on entend partout ici à
cravate or ce qu'on peut pas exactement
dire où elles sont à 10 à 15 à 20 km on
entend encore plus quand on commence à
aller dans les dents les routes de
campagne autour de cette ville je vais
vous citer les chiffres officiels qui ne
sont communiquées par les autorités
ukrainiennes dans la seule journée
d'hier dimanche dans la région de
donetsk où je me trouve il ya eu 19
frappe sur onze localités et deux morts
et dix blessés sont à déplorer et dans
la matinée un immeuble de deux étages a
été entièrement détruits à tord est ce
que dans un nouveau dans un autre
bombardement ça c'est à 50 km au sud de
créateurs ce que nous nous trouvons et
il y a six morts toujours selon les
autorités locales d'autres bombardements
ont ciblé dans le pays mikolaj f karkhiv
ni pro donc les bombardements continus
pour autant il n'y a pas vraiment de
changement sur le front les lignes de
fronts restent inchangées et les
autorités ukrainiennes affirme même
repoussé des offensives ici dans le
combat surtout au niveau de la localité
de ben aknoun
ludovic vous êtes en train de l'enquêté
sur ses accusations formulées on les a
entendu ces dernières semaines par les
ukrainiens qui accuse les russes
d'utiliser le blé comme une arme de
guerre qu'en est il au juste
oui c'est vrai c'était un sujet sur
lequel on est en train de travailler on
était justement en tournage ce matin on
a pu discuter avec un fermier on a pu
discuter avec un pompier on a pu
discuter aussi par téléphone avec une
responsable presse des services de
réponse d'urgence de l'oblast de deux
nièces qu elle nous a affirmé que pour
la seule journée d'hier dimanche quatre
incendies s'étaient déclarés sur des
champs et que 55 hectares et demi de blé
étaient partis en fumée j'ai voulu
savoir s'il y avait un intérêt militaire
a ciblé ses chants dont j'ai posé la
question à cédric massy les historiens
militaires en france il m'a dit que
l'intérêt tactique
réel était qu'il n'y avait pas d'intérêt
tactique réel en réalité sauf le fait de
détruire les ressources des ennemis de
priver l'ennemi de ressources de forces
et les civils à fuir ou à les punir et
ça ça correspond complètement à ce que
les gens nous disent ici ou à ce que les
soldats nous disent également ils nous
disent que les troupes russes seraient
frustrés d'après eux de leur impuissance
à avancer au sol et que du coup par
frustration pour se venger eh bien elle
ciblerait les récoltes ou les civils
est-ce que c'est certain que les
chansons délibérément ciblé c'est ce que
pense le pompier avec lequel nous avons
discuté est ce que ça pourrait être des
conséquences d'autres frappes qui
ciblerait d'autre chose ça c'est à
vérifier mais en ce qui nous parle le
pompier à qui on a parlé ce matin en
tout cas nous a montré une bombe à
sous-munitions d'après lui qui avait
détruit les récoltes sur un champ et
pour lui ça ne fait aucun doute les
frappes russe sur le blé ukrainien sont
intentionnels